so
today we have a cadet from the academy
speaking to us
and she's the oldest of five children
and one of the other ones also attend
west point
so that's that's a family tradition
there at that point
everyone please welcome
sydney to the stage as he mentioned i'm
sydney i'm a cadet my third year at the
united states military academy
and i'm very excited to speak to you all
today about a project that my partner
and i have been working on this semester
so unfortunately my partner is not able
to speak with me today so i'll be
presenting for both of us
the two of us have created an app in our
shiny that allows the user to examine
trends and the side effects of stem cell
transplant treatments over time
so we started this project over the
summer where the two of us shadowed dr
sean devlin who's a biostatistician at
memorial sloan kettering cancer center
dr devlin gave us access to
de-identified data from patients who had
undergone hematopoietic
stem cell transplants to treat certain
blood cancers
so during these treatments the patient
undergoes extreme chemotherapy and
radiation
treatments
um this results in the destruction of
the cancer but it also destroys many of
the patient's blood cells
so after the cancer has been eliminated
the patient is given transplants of stem
cells and these either come from
a sample of blood taken from the patient
before they're treated for the cancer or
from a donor
so autologous treatments are
treatments that use stem cells from the
actual patient
and allogeneic transplants use stem
cells from donors and each of these
transplant types has its own set of
possible complications
allogeneic transplants especially have a
host of undesirable side effects
and one of the most serious of these
side effects
is called grafts versus host disease
this is where the immune system and the
donor cells
attack the host cells because they don't
recognize them as their own
so a common method used to mitigate the
threat of severe grasp versus host
disease is to deplete the donor cells of
t cells
um before they're transplanted to the
patient
and this minimizes the risk that these
cells are going to react negatively
to the host body
another
variable in grafts versus host disease
is donor selection so donors that are
closely related to the patient
or are genetically similar pose a lower
risk because the t cells in this blood
is more likely to identify the host
cells as belonging to the donor
changes in the effectiveness of t cell
depletion and identification of donors
are partially responsible for some of
the variation in the proportion of
patients suffering
from grass versus host disease after
allogenei treatments
so in addition to all of these different
variables we were also given a mix of
pediatric and adult data and this made
it difficult to know how to handle the
data so my partner and i decided that we
would break down the larger data set
into smaller data sets that were more
specific to the treatment type and the
patient being treated
so the table on the slide shows the
original data set
each row represents a patient with a
multitude of attributes
the first few columns of this table
indicate treatment specifications
so that would be type tcd
htc type and service
and the remaining columns up until the
very last column are composed of binary
results represented by zeros and ones so
this is pretty simple whether or not the
patient experienced x negative side
effect or not
um and from now on i'm going to refer to
these side effects interchangeably as
toxicities
and then finally the last column in the
data set indicates the quarter in which
this patient was treated
so these quarters range from negative 19
to zero where zero is the present
quarter so we were given five years
worth of data
on this slide you can see how we
modified the original data into
data that was easier to work with
so first we broke the original data set
down into pediatric and adult data
we further divided those data sets into
autologous and allogeneic data
and then lastly we took the allogeneic
data and we split it up into the
different treatment types so these
treatment types just refer to the way
that the donor blood was collected and
delivered to the patient
um
as well as whether or not the blood was
depleted of t cells before it was
transplanted
so for each of these data sets we found
the proportion of patients that
experienced each toxicity per quarter so
this gave us a total of 14 data sets
with 20 rows each
and this table shows one of our
finalized data sets that went into our
app so as you can see each column is a
toxicity
and then on the right the last column is
the ordered quarter and we have one
entry per ordered quarter
and then the individual cells represent
the proportion of patients that quarter
who experience that negative side effect
so once we had our data sets we set
about creating our app using shiny
the basic features of this app include
data visualization
linear regression equations with
associated r squared values and a table
of outliers
so
pretty quickly i'm going to give you a
demonstration of how the app works
so this is our app right here
and as you can see the app allows the
user to view the proportion of patients
who experienced each toxicity per
quarter for the data set of their choice
so first the user can choose their data
set
and these are the finalized 14 data sets
that i was talking about originally
[Music]
and then next they can choose the
toxicity of their choice from within
that data set and this toxicity list
will update
once you choose a different data set
so this data is displayed in scatter
plots with trend lines that show
the change in the proportion of patients
experiencing each toxicity
over time for the data set of the user's
choice
we used plotly to make the scatter plot
so the user can hover over points
um and see the coordinate where x is the
quarter and y is the proportion
and since some of these linear
regressions
predicted
proportions less than zero
all negative predictions were changed to
zero
so as you can see here this trend line
would have gone negative but we changed
it to zero
and then finally with the slider bar you
can change the standard deviation
of the residuals um that you would like
to consider normal
so when you change that it updates the
gray area around the line of best fit
so
this second tab will show you the
regression equation
and the r squared value from your data
set and toxicity of choice
and then finally in this third tab
um
a table is displayed of all ordered
quarters
with data points that are outside the
given tolerance that you set right here
so when you change the standard
deviation again this will update
the data points
and the intent to this tab is just to
help the user identify quarters where
the proportions are significantly
different
than the rest so they can investigate
possible causes
and so although proportions that fall
below the given tolerance indicate
success rather than failure because it
means that a lower proportion of
patients experience the negative side
effects we still included them in the
table
because this is for medical
professionals
so we just thought it's best to leave
all the data in there
so moving on to interpreting results
there are three basic ways that we can
analyze the results from this app
so first we can look at the slope
of the trend lines
second we can look at outliers in the
output table
and third we can compare results across
treatment types
so the results of this app show that for
most transplant methods and toxicities
the proportion of patients experiencing
the toxicity
um
decreased over time and this is
obviously a good thing
and then some exceptions are shown on
the slide so on the left
we have one exception that doesn't
necessarily cause concern
um
and this happens when the proportions of
most of the quarters hover around zero
and these trends trend lines are often
horizontal like this
um but that doesn't mean that it's bad
just because it's not negative because
obviously proportions are never going to
go below zero the trend lines however
that do cause concern are like this
picture on the right
where it's positive
so this is an example of the proportion
of adult patients
who were readmitted to the hospital
within 30 days of an autologous
treatment
so this uptick in readmittance may not
necessarily be a bad thing i could
simply be the result of a change in
protocol
increase in precaution
etc either way it's worth investigating
so as i mentioned before the second way
we can interpret the results of this
data as comparison across treatments
so just some general trends autologous
treatments in general
had lower rates of serious
toxicities and lower rates of fatality
and this is to be expected
just because there are fewer risks
associated
with using blood from the patient as
opposed to using blood from a donor
however there were more risky and less
risky allogeneic treatments
within that subset so the allogeneic
treatment that appears to be the
riskiest
is a treatment that uses unmodified bone
marrow this treatment had very high
standard deviation
and very high average mortality
mortality rate
in general uh t cell depleted
transplants also showed lower proportion
of patients experiencing toxicities
especially when you're considering grass
versus host disease
and suboptimal cell dose
and what's really interesting is
actually that the toxicity of patients
with suboptimal cell dose was zero for
every single t cell depleted
uh t cell depleted
treatment
so while the aftermortality rate across
quarters was about the same for t cell
depleted transplants as it was
for transplants where they did not
deplete the t cells
um the trend lines for t cell depleted
transplants have more negative slopes so
this kind of indicates that
the hospital is getting better faster
at treatments where they deplete the t
cells than where they don't
so we can't say that the treatments
alone
are the cause of all these variations
because treatments are assigned to
patients based on conditions that affect
their proclivity for each toxicity
already
and our app is merely a display of the
data that medical professionals will be
able to interpret
and then finally the third way to
analyze our results is by looking at
outliers in our data
so this example shows
the results from adults
who received allogeneic treatments
and got third or fourth grade grafts
versus host disease
within 100 days
so the point at quarter negative 17
marked by this orange star right here is
disproportionately very high
compared to the rest of the data
so
we had dr devlin look into this outlier
and he found that sloan kettering
had tried out a new protocol during this
quarter which was not successful so this
just kind of shows a real life example
of where you could look at an outlier
and find a tangible reason for why it
was out of whack
and so while my partner and i lack the
medical knowledge and history of
hospital protocols
to fully interpret results like this
the target audience of this app is the
doctors biostatisticians like dr devlin
at sloan kettering
who will actually know the medicine
behind the numbers so the intent for
them is to interpret these results
and use their findings to improve stem
cell treatments
and also to better know when to use
which stem cell treatment
so in the future we would like to
improve our app um
we would like to allow the user to first
set a range of quarters that they would
like to see the trend line for
so this addition would allow the user to
view regression lines and outliers
over specific time periods
and this could be helpful to analyze the
results after protocols have been added
um after protocols have been removed
things like that or maybe you know new
technology was introduced to the
hospital
we would also like to include a summary
table of all the toxicities with
positive slopes from the specified data
set so this way instead of clicking
through each data set to see where we
have positive trend lines
that'll just be an output table as soon
as you pick your data set
and then
finally the biggest challenge in
improving our app will be accounting for
certain data sets with very small sample
sizes
and these data sets almost exclusively
fall under treatments given to pediatric
patients
so
honestly this is good because it just
means that children need fewer stem cell
treatments than adults but it does make
linear regression maybe not the best
choice for these data sets so this is an
example right here
and it's the proportion of pediatric
patients who experience primary graft
failure after an allergenic treatment
so as you can see almost every data
point
the proportion is zero
except for the data points at negative
17 and negative two and these data
points show that a hundred percent
of patients had primary graph failure
for a quarter negative 17 and 75 percent
had primary graph failure for a quarter
negative two
um these numbers seem astronomically
high when you're thinking of them in
terms of proportions
um
but when my partner and i looked back
into this data set and investigated
we found that there was only one patient
in quarter negative 17
and only four patients in quarter
negative two
so obviously this is not a large enough
sample size to derive
um really meaningful results from a
linear regression
so an alternative method that we thought
we um could implement for these data
sets is fischer's exact test
and this would help out a lot with these
data sets because that test has no
has no qualifications for sample size or
anything like that so we are looking
back into that
and then other applications of our data
set um
just kind of include different ways that
this method can be used to visualize
data so while our application is
specifically for stem cell treatments it
could be used to display trend lines
from any data set in a similar format as
the modified data that we had
and even if the new data comes in a
format similar to the original data set
given to us
the script can be
the script that we use to create the
smaller data sets can be
modified with very minimal adjustments
to apply to other data sets
additionally
these linear regressions can be
fine-tuned
using hospital data that my partner and
i don't have access to
so because of patient confidentiality
dr devlin had to clean all data of any
identifying features before we could use
it so this includes potentially very
impactful variables um like patient age
gender
pre-existing conditions things like that
which was really unfortunate but
patient attributes like these could be
easily inserted into data sets
in the regression equations especially
by biostatisticians
because our our script is pretty
intuitive
um and these variables could provide
even more information on the success of
stem cell treatments within smaller
subsets
of the groups that we already have
so our hope is just that um this app can
help sloan kettering
advance their stem cell treatments
um
maybe that they could even use this app
for other data sets as well
and before i close out i would just like
to thank you all for listening to me
today um it was a great opportunity and
i'm very flattered to be chosen
for this um thank you to our hosts you
guys put on a great conference
and then lastly thank thank you to my
project partner tobias who couldn't be
here but is super smart helped me create
this app and then to my research advisor
major lasseter for guiding us along the
way